pedophile the word alone is enough to
send shivers down my spine the innocence
of childhood is precious and we must
protect it at least 80,000 people in the
UK a thought to pose a threat to
children and anybody that violates
children must face the full width of the
law child abuse is sick and twisted but
the best protection for our children is
surely the prevention of them being
abused in the first place
the uncomfortable truth however
unpalatable it may be to us is that
there are people out there who are
sexually attracted to children many of
these people don't want to act on their
urges but they are being failed because
that support service isn't adequately
available if we are serious about
protecting our children then of course
punishment for child abusers is
absolutely essential but then so too
must be helping pedophiles in order to
stop them ever becoming child abusers in
the first place the show you and I have
been working together on the show for a
number of years and I just some of the
words I'm hearing you're talking about
that we've they've been failed we need
to provide a real support service and we
need to be helping pedophiles just
elaborate on what you mean because
doesn't sound like the Michelle I know
absolutely so I feel that and this is a
really uncomfortable topic for me the
whole thing is just not a pleasant
conversation so it's really I've had to
soul-search because my my opinion hasn't
come naturally to me but what I feel is
that and maybe it's based on an
experience I had when I was younger when
I knew children that were sexually
abused by their father and what it came
out was that the father he himself when
he was a child was a victim of sex abuse
as a child and that left me with a view
that he's wiring wasn't quite right that
what had happened to him as a child and
I'm not a psychiatrist so I don't know
what backs us up but what would happen
to this
that when he was a little boy had
somehow affected his views and all the
rest of it and I cannot help but feel if
that boy was helped and supported he
probably wouldn't have gone on or
there's a chance that he wouldn't have
gone on to become a child that's the
victims do you want to help us well it's
a few things so I think that when a
child is a victim of a sex abuse I think
that child must be helped so strongly to
make sure that he or hair comes freely
without scarring then I also think and I
understand that this is very unpalatable
and unpopular and inconceivable for a
lot of people I do believe that there
are people out there may be watching
this program perhaps that have a sexual
attraction to children they are a
pedophile they are not a child abuse
that they haven't gone on to abused
children and maybe they never will but
if we as a society are not able to
accept that those people exist however
uncomfortable it is but just lastly
before I yield I not an expert in this
field by any way but I thought it was
almost impossible to rid I'm going to
use the classic example of a man to rid
a man if he finds himself sexually drawn
to him I thought it's one of the most
difficult things to turn around psyche
as a psychology psychologically or
sidecut with a psychiatrist
I'm sure it's incredibly difficult but
that shouldn't be attempted when you
actually look into this as I have
extensively before I did this to bear
there are a number of people that talk
that that regard themselves as
pedophiles that will admit anonymously
they have desires towards children and
they are asking for help they are saying
outwardly I know that this is wrong I
hate myself I need some help I need some
support and I am saying about help and
that support is not there and before I
bring I'll bring Greg in I'll show you a
quote from the CEO of a helpline called
stop it now that's been set up to try
and help people in the situation today
there's been 214 calls trying to get
through haven't been able to get through
we've answered 15 calls and dealt with
them clearly a call is we expect about
half of those calls to be from
perpetrators of online or offline child
sexual abuse or mental by their sexual
thoughts so they're clearly complex
calls to deal with they're in a position
to make changes in their life today or
to be a risk to children today so we
have to handle them properly to make
sure that the risk to children is
reduced and those guys are starting a
journey of of getting sorted out but far
far too many people are not getting
through biggis right now we don't have
the capacity and that's wrong they
should have the capacity so it's all
well and good throwing money at
prosecuting people when they've
performed the acts of child abuse but
what I'm suggesting is that we need to
invest much more in preventing it yeah
the the the Chief Constable Simon Bailey
who is the national police chief's
person on child protection he agrees
with you to some extent if you listen to
this quote he says child sexual abuse
cannot be countered by enforcement alone
alongside the important role for
education in raising awareness and the
greater role for technology companies in
child protection it is also crucial that
offenders or yet to be arrested are
given the opportunity to seek help now
actually I know someone who distantly
who is currently in jail for looking at
child sexual abuse online we've been in
jail for some months is that wouldn't
treatment have helped more than just
putting him into jail I don't know I
think coz it's a crimson so when you
look at child abuse online you're
looking at a crime scene when people
watch the child's poor and there is no
such thing as child porn it is a it's a
crime scene that you're watching and I
think when you start watching that stuff
you absolutely should be prosecuted or
whatever because it's illegal it's a
crime what I think though is I want to
stop people even getting to the point of
wanting to watch that and act and it's
just wrong what do you think Trevor well
a bit puzzled about how you would ever
make any of this work I mean most you're
completely correct that a
disproportionate number of people who
commit offences are themselves people
who have suffered abuse as children but
much as people will never tell anybody
that is the case and no more number too
many of the people who have suffered in
fact most people who have suffered abuse
are not themselves abuses so if you were
to say okay will will
identify people by the fact that they
themselves had some experience as a
child you'd actually be dealing with a
group most of whom are not likely to
offend and the other point out simply
that there's three men sitting at this
table how do you know which one of us is
a potential pedophile well okay so let
me ask whether all of us opportunity
right first things first pedophiles are
not just men that's my first point my
second point is you say well how would I
make this work it's not about sitting
around the table and guessing who's a
pedophile and who's not in Germany they
do this that they do what I'm suggesting
they have a service where people then
people know if you're a man or a woman
that has a sexual desire towards a child
you know that that is your your thought
process you yourself know and you
probably also know that it's wrong so
these people themselves are asking for
this help and what I'm saying is that
this service does not exist so in
Germany before I bring in Rachel they
have project project dum-dum call fells
where people anonymously contact
therapists these guys are given a
protected environment to talk about what
what is going on in their head and they
are supported and hopefully and it says
here 80 to 85 percent of these people
are what they call reformed and do not
go on to abuse children they voluntarily
come forward yes yeah okay yes I agree
with I think Michelle's right that it's
far better that you know you we stopped
this happening before it happens but you
know the criminal justice system has
actually said it's not equipped to deal
with the number of child potential child
abusers and potential pedophiles and
actual pedophiles that are out there I
think there are 80,000 potential people
who pose a threat to children online so
if anything can be done within either
the criminal justice system or the NHS
or both of them working together to
enhance the access available to these
people if they feel they can come
forward to seek help oh let's let's
please bring it on steady steady this is
this I'm gonna push back against this I
mentioned somebody he knew I don't know
if any of you has actually ever met an
actual self-confessed beautiful okay
well I had the pleasure
let's and using that word ironically of
spending three days in a room with a
series of these guys when I made a
documentary it's long going back a long
way and let me be absolutely clear most
of them thought what they did was fine
actually most of them thought it was
fine now there may be the odd person who
says I'm thick and all the rest of it
but actually it is the nature of this
particular condition that most of the
men particularly involved think it's
okay and I want to ask you the question
if a serial rapist came forward and said
you know I can't help myself would you
be saying let's you know let's put them
in a project I mean it'd be absolutely
clear I do not condone and pedophilia
and I do not that's not the question I'm
asked you know what I'm saying is no I
do not think there anybody serial or
otherwise that touches or abuse as a
child is okay I am NOT suggesting that
what I'm saying is some people have
warped mindsets they do think that what
they do or think is okay and often not
always often that has come from their
experiences of affection intimacy has
come from their and father
there are mother abusing them and
they're wiring is wrong we need to help
those people in order to protect our
children
you